[Music]
hello actually that's hello in bowerbird
oniy for the typographically hysterical
amongst us one of the threads that seems
to have come through loud and clear in
the last couple of days is this need to
reconcile what the big ones the big
being the organization the system the
country and what the small wants the
individual the person and how do you
bring those two things together Charlie
Ledbetter yesterday I thought talked
very articulately about this need to
bring consumers to bring people into the
process of creating things and and
that's what I want to talk about today
so bringing together the small to help
facilitate and create the big I think is
something that we believe in something I
believe in there's something that we
kind of bring to life through what we do
at IDEO I call this first chapter for
the Brits in the room the blinding
glimpse of the bleeding obvious often
the good ideas are so staring at you
right in the face that you kind of
missed them and I think a lot of times
what we do is just sort of hold the
mirror up to our clients and sort of go
you know look what's really going on and
rather than talk about in the theory I
think I'm just gonna show you an example
we were asked by a large healthcare
system in Minnesota to describe to them
what their patient experience was and I
think they were expecting they'd worked
with lots of consultants before I think
they were expecting some kind of hideous
org chart with thousands of bubbles and
systemic this that and the other and all
kinds of mind nappy stuff or even worse
some kind of ghastly death by PowerPoint
thing with wow charts and all kinds of
you know God knows whatever the first
thing we actually shared with them was
was this our players into your eyeballs
completely dissolved this is fifty nine
seconds into the film this is a minute
fifty nine
three minutes nineteen I think something
happens I think the head may appear in a
second
five minutes ten five minutes 58 six
minutes twenty we showed them the hole
cut and they were all completely what
what is this and the point is when you
lie in a hospital bed all day all you do
is look at the roof and it's a really
shitty experience and just putting
yourself in the position of the patient
this is Christian who works with us at
IDEO he just lay in the hospital bed and
come have stared at their polystyrene
ceiling tiles for a really long time
that's what it's like to be a patient in
the hospital and they were sort of you
know blinding glimpse of bleeding
obvious oh my goodness so looking at the
situation from the point of view of the
person out as opposed to the traditional
physician of the organization in was for
these guys quite a revelation and so
that was a really catalytic thing for
them so they snapped into action they
said okay it's not about systemic change
it's not about huge ridiculous things
that we need to do it's about tiny
things that can make a huge amount of
difference so we started with them
prototyping some really little things
that we could do to have a huge amount
of impact the first thing we did was we
took a little bicycle mirror and we
band-aided it here onto a gurney a
hospital trolley so that when you were
wheeled around by a nurse or by a doctor
you could actually have a conversation
with them you could kind of see them in
your rear-view mirror so it created a
tiny human interaction very small
example of something that they could do
interesting the nurses themselves sort
of snapped into action said okay we kind
of embraced this what can we do the
first thing they did was they decorated
the ceiling so it was room I show this
to my mother recently I think my mother
now thinks that I'm some sort of
interior decorators what I do for a
living
so laurence llewelyn bowen not
particularly the world's best design
solution for those of us who are real
sort of hard core designers but
nonetheless a fabulous empathic solution
for people things that they started
doing themselves like changing the floor
all going into the patient's room so
that it signified this is my room this
is my personal space was a really
interesting sort of design solution to
the problem so he went from public space
to private space and another idea again
that came from one of the nurses which I
love was they took traditional sort of
corporate whiteboards then they put them
on one wall of the patient's room and
they put this sticker there so that what
you could actually do was go into the
room and write messages to the person
who was sick in that room which is
lovely so tiny tiny tiny solutions that
made a huge amount of impact I thought
that was a really really nice example so
this is not particularly a new idea kind
of seeing opportunities in things that
are around you and kind of snapping and
turning them into a solution that's a
history of invention based around this
I'm gonna read this because I want to
get these names right Joan Ganz Cooney
saw her daughter came down on a Saturday
morning saw her daughter watching the
test card waiting for programs to come
on one morning and from that came Sesame
Street Malcolm McLean was moving from
one country to another and was wondering
why it took these guys so long to get
the boxes onto the ship and he invented
the shipping container George de Mestral
this is not bugs all over at Birkenstock
he was walking his dog in a field and
got covered in burrs sort of a tall
prickly things and from that came velcro
and finally for the Brits Percy Shores
is a bit of big British invention saw
the cat's eyes at the side of the road
when he was driving home one night and
from that came the cat's eye so the
whole series of just using your eyes
seeing things for the first time seeing
things afresh and using that as an
opportunity to create new possibilities
second one without sounding overly Zen
this is a quote from the Buddha finding
yourself in the margins looking to the
edges of things it's often a really
interesting place to start
blinkered vision tends to produce I
think blinkered solutions so looking
wide using your peripheral vision is a
really interesting place to look for
opportunity again another medical
example here
we were asked by a device producer we
did the Palm Pilot in the tria we did a
lot of sexy tech at IDEO they'd seen
this and they wanted a sexy piece of
technology for medical diagnostics but
this was a device that a nurse uses when
they're doing a spinal procedure in
hospital I asked the nurses to input
data and they had this vision of the
nurse kind of clicking away on this
aluminum device and it all being
incredibly sort of gadget lust ish when
we actually went and watched this
procedure taking place on I'll explain
this in a second it became very obvious
that there was a human dimension to this
that they really weren't recognizing
when you're having a four inch needle
inserted into your spine which was the
procedure that this devices data was
about for pain management you're [ __ ]
scared you're freaking out and so the
first thing that pretty much every nurse
did was hold the patient's hand to
comfort them human gesture which made
the fabulous two-handed data input
completely impossible so the thing that
we designed much less sexy but much more
human and practical was this so it's not
a Palm Pilot by any stretch of the
imagination but it has a thumb scroll so
you can do everything with one hand so
again going back to this the idea that a
tiny human gesture dictated the design
of this product and I think that's
really really important so again this
idea of workarounds we use of the wrist
users phrase workarounds are sort of
looking around us I was actually looking
around but Ted and just watching all of
these kind of things happen while I've
been here this idea of the way that
people cobbled together solutions in our
life and the things we kind of do in our
environment there are somewhat
subconscious but have huge potential is
something that we look at a lot we wrote
a book written Enders I think you might
have received a call thoughtless acts
and it's been all about these kind of
thoughtless things that people do which
have huge intention and huge opportunity
why do we all follow the line in the
street this is a picture in Japanese
subway people consciously follow things
even though why we don't know
why do we line up the square milk carton
with the square fence because we kind of
have to
we're just compelled to we don't know
why but we do why do we wrap the teabag
string around the cup handle again we're
sort of using the world around us to
create our own design solutions and
we're always saying to our clients you
should look at this stuff this stuff is
really important the stuff is really
vital this is people designing their own
experiences you can draw from this we
sort of assumed that because there's a
pole in the street that it's okay to use
it so we park our shopping cart there
it's there for our use and some some
levels so we again we sort of co-opt our
environment to do all these different
things we co-opt other experience as we
take one item and transfer it to another
and this is my favorite one my mother
used to say to me just because your
sister jumps in the lake doesn't mean
you have to but of course we all do we
all follow each other every day so
somebody assumes that because somebody
else has done something that's
permission for them to do the same thing
and there's almost this sort of
semaphore around us all the time I mean
shopping bag equals parking meter out of
order and we all kind of know how to
read these signals now we all kind of
talk to one another in this a highly
visual way without realizing what we're
doing third section is this idea of not
knowing of consciously putting yourself
backwards I took about unthinking
situations all the time sort of having
beginner's mind scraping your mind
cleaner sort of looking at things afresh
a friend of mine was a designer at IKEA
and he was asked by his boss to help
design a storage system for children
this is the billy bookcase it's like
Kia's biggest selling product hammer it
together hammer it together with a shoe
if you're me because they're impossible
to assemble but big selling bookcase how
do we how do we replicate this for
children the reality is when you
actually watch children children don't
think about things like storage in
linear terms children assume permission
in a very different way children live on
things they live under things they live
around things and so that there's a
spatial relationship and they're
thinking around storage is totally
different so the first thing you have to
do
this is Graham for designer it's sort of
put yourself in their shoes and so here
he is sitting under the table so what
came out of this this is the storage
system that he designed so what is this
I hear you all ask no I don't it's it's
this and I think this is a particularly
lovely solution so you know it's a
totally different way of looking at the
situation it's a completely empathic
solution apart from the fact that
Teddy's probably not loving it that's a
really nice way of reframing the
ordinary and I think that's one of the
things and putting yourself in the
position of the person and I think
that's one of threads that I've heard
again from from this conference is how
do we put us off in other people's shoes
and really feel what they feel and then
use that information to fuel solutions
and I think that's that's what this is
very much about last section Green Line
bands you've all gotten is about this
really I mean it's about picking battles
big enough to matter but small enough to
win again that's one of the themes that
I think has come through loud and clear
in this conference is where do we start
how do we start what do we do to start
so again we were asked to design a water
pump for a company called afro tech in
Kenya the now called kickstart and again
as designers we wanted to make this
thing incredibly beautiful and spend a
lot of time thinking of the form and
that was completely irrelevant when you
put yourself in the position of these
people things like the fact that this
has to be able to fold up and fit on a
bicycle become much more relevant than
the form of it the way it's produced it
has to be produced with indigenous in
manufacturing methods and indigenous
materials so it had to be looked at
completely from the point of view of the
user we have to completely transfer
ourselves over to their world so what
seems like a very clunky product is in
fact incredibly useful it's powered a
bit like a Stairmaster you pump up and
down on it children can use it adults
can use it everybody uses it it's
turning these guys at one again one of
the themes it's turning them into
entrepreneurs
these guys are using this and very
successful and for us it's been great
because it won loads design awards so we
actually managed to reconcile the needs
of the design company but needs of the
individuals and the company to feel good
about a product we were actually
designing and the needs of the
individuals that we were designing it
for there it is pumping water from 30
feet so as a final gesture we handed out
these bracelets to all of you this
morning we've made a donation on
everybody's behalf here to kick-start no
pun intended their next project because
again I think sort of putting our money
where our mouth is here we feel that
this is an important gesture so we've
handed up race that small as a new bake
I hope you'll all wear them so that's it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]